you know I haven't done a long time a
multi prop Drex challenge so guess what
we're gonna do today
drexy your friend Rex vector comm
bringing you poi spinning in flow arts
to benefit your body and brain and today
we are going back to that old mainstay
the multi prop directs challenge so that
you can take some of the stuff that I'm
doing and apply it to any prop that you
might encounter before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk Flo toys pirate aerolite toys
lmf props spin balls and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
Flo artists like yourself by checking
out the links that have got down in the
description of this video well goodness
gracious my friends we are officially in
the middle of a DC summer so it is
weltering out and I am probably only
gonna get more sweaty in the course of
making this video I apologize so on
other topics yeah I'm right in the
middle of preparing for Drex fest 2020
which you should go get tickets if you
haven't already crowdcast
IO / e / it directs fest 2020 and in the
meantime I'm gonna give you two combos
that are going to be meant to be kind of
quick filler stuff and everything and
have some more interesting stuff coming
tour for you later on in the month so as
bizarre as that's going to sound I think
that the one and only prerequisite for
getting down this week's combo is
actually just knowing how to do wall
plain anti-spin flowers we're going to
be dealing with some other stuff that I
think is going to make more sense in
context and everything but for all
intents and purposes the only thing
that's a deal breaker is that trick that
leads it off so I'll go ahead and leave
a link to a tutorial for that trick down
in the description or up in the cards if
you happen to be watching this video on
YouTube I'll show you the combo at full
speed it take you through a piece by
piece and then show to you again in
slow-mo
alright so there's some plane breaking
in here because it's me and that's what
I've been playing with yeah sorry anyhow
we're gonna start this off by going
ahead and just doing our wall plane
anti-spin flowers and we're gonna put a
little linear isolation in the middle of
that so we have this lovely moment where
it looks like the two props are crossing
over each other and kind of isolating
for a second if you happen to be doing
this combo with poi I would recommend
shortening them up a little bit because
it's going to help you at the very end
but just to start off with go ahead and
give me three of these wall plane
anti-spin flowers yeah going through
once twice and three times and that's
where things change so for literally any
other prop besides poi this moment right
here is no big deal because you don't
have to fight gravity but we're poised
spinners so we have made a mistake right
here's what you're going to want to do
here basically I'm gonna go ahead and
just show you what this looks like with
each poi individually so as my underhand
poi comes around in everything that is
the one that is spinning clockwise my
right hand poi it is gonna wind up
getting caught by my left hand as it
comes through that spot right there
whereas the which means you get the left
hand poi is going to wind up kind of
sitting on top of the right hand yeah so
if you put those two things together
boom boom and excuse me the left hand
catches and the right hand just kind of
lets the tether sit on top right there
once again if you're working with any
prop other than poi this is less of a
big deal but if you are dealing with a
prop that looks different depending upon
the angle like say fans for example this
is going to be your opportunity to
switch the plane that they're operating
in so that they turn into a horizontal
plane instead of a vertical plane next
we're going to go ahead and switch into
some horizontal flowers here so I want
you to go ahead and let your props go
and
do a quick peddle and then behind a
quick pedal and then cross a quick pedal
and then behind a quick pedal and then
coming right into the middle here yeah
so this is when things are gonna change
a little bit and I'm guessing that those
of you out there that are not spinning
poi are going to have to kind of bring
your props together and do another plane
shift on them namely coming together and
then flip them up vertical but that's
gonna look like for the poi instead is
actually when we stall out and back
across and then out and then back across
the last time we do this we're instead
going to stall the poi towards our
middle and that becomes a point at which
we switch into a buzzsaw right here yeah
it's a buzzsaw no matter what your prop
is but once again you might need to
switch your plane of your prop if it
happens to be a bladed prop when we come
in like this you're going to need
probably need to take a moment to flip
which dimension is the long way around
on the prop yeah and we just finish this
off by going ahead with the poi and we
will wrap them around our hands and I
will drop my right hand and keep my left
hand up and we do just like a little
dramatic moment about that right okay so
let's take all that again from the top
so we are gonna do our wall plane
flowers once twice and on the third time
boom we catch it if you're using any
proper than pull you might have to
switch your plane we push them out doing
a pedal out and a pedal across a pedal
out a pedal across and the third time
pedal out pedal in and we boom switch it
to a buzzsaw and then we wrap the poi up
to stop it or you just kind of take your
rigid prop and point one down and one up
to cap that one off yeah cool let's see
that again in slow-mo
[Music]
awesome I would love to see your version
of this combo please post video of
yourself doing it to Instagram and use
the hashtag der x-factor POI or post it
to your stories and tag me I am directs
factor on Instagram if you do so I will
copy your video over to my own stories
so that my followers can see your hard
work please make sure to LIKE share
comment and subscribe so that other
people can find these videos and
hopefully learn some more props spinning
themselves and of course a huge thank
you to my wonderful supporters on
patreon without him this video and all
the videos on this channel might not
exist if you would like to send to
support the work that I do and I totally
appreciate it if that is something that
is not within your means right now
especially with the world being crazy
like it is but if it is I would
appreciate it if you headed on over to
patreon comm slash directs factor POI
and signed up you can get early access
to all of my content as well as a say in
what topics I tackle in the future
please and thank you oh and make sure
you come to directs Fest this weekend
again it's broadcast
IO / e / directs fest 2020 it's July 11
1012 please come